no surprise here unfortunately a man
accused of attacking comedian dave
chappelle on the stage of the hollywood
bowl tuesday evening will not face
felony charges according to the los
angeles time the 23 year old man was
originally arrested for assault with a
deadly weapon after rushing the stage
authorities told the los angeles times
that the man did not brandish the weapon
during the assault
the los angeles district attorney's
office has forwarded the case to the los
angeles city attorney's office which
handles misdemeanor crimes within the
city
uh spell was performing on stage for a
netflix comedy special when he was
assailed it did not appear he was
injured by the assault so
this
this is someone who rushed on stage in
the middle of this comedy festival
and tackled dave chappelle to the ground
and had a deadly weapon on him he had a
knife that was oddly enough hidden
inside a replica gun that part i don't
understand well i do understand it this
guy's a lunatic so there's a lunatic who
physically attacked dave chappelle on
stage had a knife on him
and the los angeles district attorney
desperately looking for any reason
you know to um
let a violent criminal off the hook what
they're saying is well he didn't
technically brandish the weapon he just
had it on him
and who knows if he intended to use it
you know this is a crazy guy who rushed
the stage during this comedy special
tackled somebody on the ground had a
knife on him but we don't know if he was
going to use it he maybe had the knife
who knows maybe he was just before that
he was cutting apples with and that's
why he had the knife for a snack he was
slicing the cheese and apples
so that's a misdemeanor charge
if you're wondering why our cities are
plagued by crime um
this is the reason why and there's
there's just
you don't do that
but you don't let somebody like that off
the hook with a misdemeanor
twist twisting yourself into logical
pretzels here to to justify making that
a misdemeanor crime you don't do that
um unless you want more crime
which
in the end is what these people actually
want and i think they also want i i
think of especially on the the radical
leftists
they are especially happy with a
scenario where comedians on stage now
have to worry especially if you're in
california
you know you have to worry about what
you're saying because if you say
anything if you tell a joke somebody
doesn't like they could just rush the
stage
and assault you
because now we have two high-profile
examples of that happening of a comedian
in a span of just a few weeks
a comedian being assaulted physically
assaulted on stage and in one case there
were no criminal charges the other case
may be a misdemeanor although they
haven't even confirmed that there will
be a misdemeanor charge there might be
no charge at all
so again you don't you don't do that
unless you actually want more of that
kind of behavior which is what you're
going to get
telling people words are violence jokes
are
are harmful
and then also letting them know you know
with a
a wink and a nudge that hey
if you assault a comedian on stage
maybe you'll get a fine at most
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated